hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Walking Dead episode 9 video we
are back goodbye to filler episodes so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet the really cool thing too is
that for the next couple of episodes the
runtime will be just a little bit longer
than normal now there won't be super
long episodes but they will be a little
bit longer so that's why you know it
goes past the hour mark be sure to stick
around for big twists like at the end of
this episode so that's actually a comic
book group they're doing things right
out of march to war volume 19 so I'll
say new round of the giveaway starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
it's for a $20 Amazon gift card you can
spend it on Walking Dead comics if you
want to read along during volume 19 or
you can read ahead if you want to let's
do top 10 WTF and comic book Easter eggs
let me know if the audio is a little bit
better I also change my microphone
placement just a little bit but number
10 the Gabriel's WTF opening scene
stealing all those supplies so he's been
super shady in the past predictably when
they found out half the group wanted to
kill him on the spot he's turned on as
he stole all the supplies the Rick wants
to believe the good in him and they find
a clue
it's a hat tip to the end of last season
when they were on the houseboat so it
all comes back around just wait for the
twist sure enough at the end of the
episode they totally paid it off those
that have faith in Father Gabriel will
totally be rewarded but I love the
silence of that opening scene you're
just waiting for something crazy to
happen like a jump scare nothing good
ever happens when it's that quiet for
that long
and if you didn't pick up on it the
opening scene picks up in the immediate
moment after the binoculars are watching
Gabriel and like a post-credits scene
from episode 8 the boots that we're
watching Rick and Aaron on the houseboat
and in the same boots the same person
watching Gabriel in the safe zone
through the binoculars they're also part
of my WTF later on the list so I'll
explain them in just a second number 9
is Rick's group vs. Gregory so there
were a lot of new threats in the episode
Gregory is the biggest one he's not
necessarily a new threat but he's one of
their biggest threats because he would
do anything to preserve what he thinks
is the arrangement they have with the
Savior's but he's kind of like one of
those dogs that just rolls over at the
sign of first trouble so if you were
waiting
for Daryl to slap the mustache right off
his face you will get that opportunity
later this season
mark my words something epic and bad is
going to happen with Gregory's character
and it is going to be so satisfying for
them to pay that off because you've been
waiting this long he's been going after
Maggie you don't belong here we like the
way Maggie refers to hilltop as if she
feels like a part of the community
they're looking at her as more of a
leader
Gregory sees that as a threat that's all
part of the hilltop arc this season they
will totally pay that off and it is
going to be epic but when they walked
out and like the group was standing
there waiting for them that's the show's
way of telling you that not everybody
feels the same as Gregory not everybody
is a little [ __ ] like he is things
getting a little more exciting the
music's getting a little more hopeful
number eight Jesus reveals the kingdom
you have to remember that a lot of these
characters have no idea that it exists
they don't know who Ezekiel is so you
get that funny moment with Rick just
going king what what the hell dude what
are you talking about King so the
important thing during this rally moment
when they're talking about going to the
kingdom is they tease a couple really
big ideas the idea that the saviors have
all the satellite stations they have the
numbers but somebody floats the idea the
genius idea
that maybe people inside the Savior's
also want to get rid of negan that's
going to be very important because the
Savior's have so many people they
haven't done a good job of showing you
just how many of them there are they're
spread out over a vast distance with the
satellite communication towers I'll talk
about that in a second - that will come
back around but inside the sanctuary
they're really enclosed spaces so you
can tell there are a lot of people but
the worst-case scenario for the
survivors would be a head-on assault all
of the Savior's against all of them they
would go down instantly so that's why
Rick needs to go around and convince all
these other groups to join the fight but
that's not the end of it you also need
people inside the Savior's to help out
which is where you get to people like
Dwight and sherry that really hate
Meighan they're just trying to survive
there's other people like that inside
the Savior's - number 7 this is so funny
the Monty Python introduction to the
kingdom so they roll up everyone's just
like what is going on this is
unbelievable this is totally ridiculous
in an inn ride Monty Python style
Richard
another guy who gives them the
traditional kala who goes there
how dare you trespass on our last in and
stops dead in his tracks the minute he
sees Jesus he's like holy [ __ ] it's you
it's almost like a Renaissance Faire
where everyone's acting in a very
specific way and then they break
character the minute they see Jesus so
number six really awesome reunion with
Morgan how do you know Morgan oh we go
back to the beginning and if you
remember way back to season 1 when they
picked up with Ric he met Morgan met his
son before he died then saw him again
during season 3 when he had gone
completely batshit crazy to now so
they're just letting you know that they
have a lot of history oh we go back to
the beginning of the Apocalypse but the
whole point here is for them to just
learn what happened since the last time
they saw Morgan and Carroll and true to
his word Morgan does not tell them where
Carroll is he tells them she's alive but
she's gone and we do see her later in
the episode so you touch base with all
the really big characters but number 5
Rick makes the case to Ezekiel oh we
forgot to tell you about the tiger one
of the most funny moments in the episode
oh yeah yeah we have a tiger and then
then just reacting to all the Ezekiel
fanfare they bought that a lot faster
than Carol did but that's just because
time is of the essence things are so
urgent but it's really once a Zeo starts
hearing about all the dead people that
have died they learn about Glenn Abraham
Olivia Spenser and it's just a way to
show Ezekiel that there is no peace to
be had even though he's also really
pissed with Jesus about telling other
people what's going on with his
arrangement so if you don't remember
Ezekiel has not told all the people that
live at the kingdom about their
arrangement with the Savior's they're
giving them supplies he just wants
everyone to live a really happy life
remember he used to be a theatre actor
so he's putting on this grand play to
make everyone feel really good there was
that Martin Luther King bedtime speech
that was one of the best moments in the
episode it also kind of let you know
that Ezekiel is already made up his mind
but he's not going to rush into anything
anytime soon even though he's heard
about all these dead friends that they
have in Morgan is the one that teases
another really important idea maybe we
don't need to kill all the Savior's
maybe we just need to get rid of negan
remove the rock from the road based on
Rick's speech so Rick is telling it like
the saviors of the rock but Morgan
teased
the idea that maybe it's just negan
that's the rock so maybe there are
people inside the savior's that are
willing to help get rid of negan in
takeover which is something that's right
out of the comics so if you have read
the comics please use a spoiler tag if
you're going to talk about plot point
based on that idea but they're just
feeding special things from the comics
maybe we don't need to kill everybody
maybe we just need to get rid of negan
maybe there are other people inside the
Savior's that want to get rid of them
but all really important stuff for later
number four one of the other funniest
moments in the episode Benjamin in
Carroll I heard you coming a mile away
she tells them how to walk the right way
you shouldn't be out here after dark by
yourself kid what about you
I'm different I'm Carol I'm the
Terminator nobody messes with me just
reminding you what a badass Carol is and
that she hasn't completely given up on
the other groups she sounds like she's
still very standoffish but she'll come
back around eventually this is just like
the Ezekiel thing where he doesn't
immediately form an alliance with Rick
it's just going to take something for
her to come around I feel like that
might end up being Benjamin's death
because he's like this sweet innocent
figure you don't belong out here by
yourself kid so some really big WTF is
going to have to happen to push Carol
over the ledge push Ezekiel over the
ledge and finally decide to fight negan
even though they've kind of already made
up their minds in the back of their head
but after that speech that Benjamin gave
to Ezekiel when he was doing the MLK jr.
speech the bedtime speech free at last
thank God free at last it's all about
rising up and fighting oppression so of
course they're going to fight Meighan
but Benjamin's speech about being a hero
in being so unprepared he is the worst
fighter ever just makes it feel like he
is marked for death this season so you
guys can let me know in the comments
what you think is going to happen to
Benjamin but I feel like they're tipping
the hat just a little bit like he is so
eager to fight and be a hero but he is
so not good at fighting but number three
is a big action set piece of the episode
the highway walker trap this was so much
fun so if you weren't sure what the
whole deal was with that trap the
Savior's have a highway that leads to
the sanctuary their home base they set
up this giant trap to stop the super
herd from reaching the sanctuary so what
Rick tries to do is take all the
explosives and then rig it so this is
super hurt has a clear path to the
sanctuary so they're going to use the
super hurt against the Savior's
eventually but they move Barry's slow so
it's going to take a while so even if
they don't take care of negan himself
the super herd will be this giant
distraction for the Savior's so their
group will be split remember they have
this army of people so Rick needs to do
everything he can to split them up
because it would be certain death if
they had to face all the Savior's at the
same time it is going to be so much fun
to watch them all Zerg the sanctuary if
you remember like that was one of the
big things at the beginning of season
six then trying to deal with the super
heard there was this funny Michonne
quote where she's talking to Rick it's
okay to smile now we made it
we're the ones who live which is funny
because they're called the survivors
they're the survivors because they live
so number two Steven aughh Trevor or
whatever you want to call his name is
Simon that's the character's name that
everybody just think Simon is Trevor
from Grand Theft Auto leads the search
party for Daryl they don't find him but
it sort of tips the hat to the missing
food in the pantry and all the Gabriel
stuff that's happening so it comes back
around and they lets them know that
they're coming back for a pickup run in
a couple days which is probably next
week's episode or the episode after that
so those are just the ways the show
tells you about the ticking clock like
look there's a bomb that is slowly
counting down it's going to go off in
that bomb right now is the super hurt
it's the saviors coming back looking for
food so they're going to have to find
more people to fight them and find
supplies at the same time the really
cool thing about this they were looking
for Daryl and obviously he's still back
at the kingdom is that Rick gave him the
mission to turn Ezekiel around stare
them to death if you have to do whatever
you got to do get them into the fight so
that's going to be a big part of Daryl's
arc this season
inspiring Ezekiel so I am really excited
for the Daryl Carol reunion because
Carol is very close to the kingdom
so eventually they're going to have to
meet up at some point but number one is
the brand new group so this is the
person with the boots that was watching
Aaron and Rick on the houseboat this was
the person watching them with the
binoculars at the end of episode eight
we finally learn about the other new
group who I think is from the comics
they haven't revealed who their name is
so we'll find out next week for sure but
I think this is another one of the small
groups from the comics that's nearby
Alexandria there are three big groups
that we know about via the safe zone the
kingdom in hilltop need to band together
to fight the Savior's but there are also
other smaller pockets of people from the
comics that Rick's going to go around -
don't forget about Oceanside they have a
ton of weapons in this new group also
has a bunch of weapons so very important
they teased this big hardcore standoff
but obviously this is where Gabriel
bought the supplies - so they have a
relationship with them already they just
need to understand that Gabriel will
probably be that person so if you're
hoping for some really cool Gabriel to
back half of the season I feel like this
is going to be where it comes in but let
me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode what are you most
excited about the back half of the
season what I'm going to do next is
there's a whole bunch of videos there's
a bunch of footage that just drops so
you guys can let me know what you want
me to do next in the comments I have new
Logan footage there's new Walking Dead
footage for next week's episode there's
new Doctor Strange footage and there's
new flash just whichever you guys want
just let me know in the comments but I
will say congratulations to javo darth
you're the new Walking Dead giveaway
winner please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video all announced
the winners the next time I post a
Walking Dead video while you wait for
that to post you can click here for
brand new guardians of the galaxy
footage and you can click here for all
my other Walking Dead Season 7 videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
let's high-five I'll see you guys in the
next video